No, no, no, no.
>> Okay.
>> So, I believe that Islam is a true
because it doesn't contradiction to
itself.
>> It doesn't contradict itself.
>> Yeah. Because Muslim doesn't believe.
Muslim doesn't wait. Muslim doesn't say
that
>> uh Allah is not a god and the other
chapters say is Allah is a god.
>> Okay. But you have uh verses that say
Allah is all powerful and then verses
demonstrating that he's not all
powerful.
>> Where
>> like for example, do you believe that
Allah could have a son if he wanted?
>> What do you mean by that? Could he have
a son if he wanted to?
>> No. When when he say that it's just like
a Quranic speakers. It's mean. How I can
explain you? It's uh
>> could he have a son if he wanted?
>> No, it's got addiction to his uh nature,
the God's nature.
>> All right. So when Allah says that he
could have a son if he wanted to, does
he saying is he saying he could
contradict his nature?
>> Yes.
>> So Allah can contradict his nature.
>> No, I mean wait don't change my words.
Don't change my words.
>> I I didn't. I just I just repeated.
>> Yeah. If God have son, so it's
contradiction to his nature. Do you
agree with that?
>> No.
>> Why?
>> You you're you're saying that?
>> No. Do you agree with me?
>> I don't agree with you. And so when we
could talk about that in a second,
>> but if you're saying that Allah having a
son is a contradiction to his nature, so
when Allah says that he can have a son
if he wanted to, that means that Allah
is saying that he can contradict his
nature. Right.
>> Where where they just change the word.
>> Okay. You're right. You're right. I I
probably misqued.
>> I know about what are you saying?
>> Okay, I'm I'm sorry. I'm okay. You're
right. I'm misquing.
>> But my question is that for you,
>> but but if you relax, you still didn't
answer the question. If God said if
Allah said that he could have a son if
he wanted to, would that be Allah
acknowledging that he can contradict his
nature?
>> Where he say that?
>> I didn't say he did. I'm saying if he
said that.
>> Hypothetical.
>> Don't say that, bro. If he if he doesn't
say that,
>> bro. Hanfi, if you if you can't engage,
man, I'm going to have to move on.
>> Okay. I'm going to say I'm going to tell
you. So, is God saying so are you going
to are you going to answer the question?
If God said if Allah say it's going to
be contradiction, it's going to be
contradicts to his nature. Yes, of
course.
>> Okay. All right. Got you. So, uh if you
go to 39:4, Allah says he can have a son
if he want.
>> He doesn't say that. Which verse? Which
verse? Which verse? Which verse?
>> Chapter 39 verse 4.
>> Which verse?
>> Four.
>> Welcome everybody. Welcome everybody.
Just getting warmed up. Chapter 38
verse4.
>> Chapter 39 verse number 4. That's why I
usually don't say the verse until you
guys go to the chapter cuz I will have
to repeat it like 10 times.
>> But that's normal like normal human
beings in general. Anyway, yep guys, as
you guys are going in, we got Fearless
Truth with us. His title is in I mean
his uh YouTube is in the title of this
video. So go ahead and go to the title
of this video, click his YouTube name.
It'll take you straight to his channel
and give my brother a subscription. Make
sure you like his videos, comment on
them, help the algorithm over there.
Let's support our brother, man, as he's
doing work for the kingdom of God
because he's just so awesome.
>> Oh, wise.
>> While we wait, uh, just an example of of
why we wait in the song that we play.
>> That's Mafer. That's Mafer.
>> It's what?
>> That's Mafer.
>> I didn't I didn't understand what you
said.
>> Mafer.
>> Mafer. Well, how can you? Wait.
>> Sorry, man. I didn't understand that.
I'mma read a super chat in this in in in
the place though. So Charles says, "Hey,
big gifts.
>> Appreciate that, Romelo. Dang the
freak."
>> That's made for That's
>> all right. One one second, Hunter. So
Charles says, "Urban, California, Orange
County, but when metaphysics Mike says
something can't be a and not a at the
same time." So how can Jesus be fully
God and fully man at the same time? You
want to go ahead and answer that? Yeah.
So, when we say that Jesus is both a God
and man, and by the there's an echo like
I'm hearing. Is that just going to be
like because of
>> It might be Hanafi. Hold on. Let me mute
Hana. Let's see. All right. Go ahead.
>> Testing. I still hear Do you have
>> Do you have YouTube like or or
Streamyard going on?
>> I streamer open, but I need hit. Let me
uh
>> But you got your headphones in though.
You don't
>> Oh, yeah. I guess so. I can Okay, that
makes sense. All right, that makes
sense. So, I can just Okay. Yeah, that
makes sense. Like I just turned my phone
up on here. All right. Uh okay. Yeah. So
um when metaphysics say a and not a at
the same time, how can Jesus be fully
God, fully man? Because uh when we say a
and not a at the same time, that also
includes in the same sense, right? So
when we're saying that uh something
cannot be a and not a it has to also be
in the same sense. Now Jesus being fully
God and fully man is not in the same
sense. It's in two different senses. One
is in the human nature and one is in the
divine nature. Therefore, it does not
follow that. It breaks the law of
non-contradiction.
>> Amen. All right. So, I was saying that
the headphones should stop the echo if
you had it in.
>> Yeah. I took I was uh I still have my
headphones in on YouTube. So, icon was
hearing everything we're saying there.
It's fine now, though. We're straight.
>> Okay. All right. Hi, you see the verse?
>> Yes, that's
>> what
>> metaphor.
Oh, metaphor.
>> No, it's not a metaphor.
>> Check. You can just check what's says
>> No, it's it's not a metaphor at all. He
says that if if Allah wanted to have a
son, he could have one from any of his
creation.
>> Okay, I I can show you example of that.
I can show you example. Opens the
chapter uh chapter 20 verse 15.
>> How does that answer this?
>> I'm just shower. I'm going to show you
that
>> a metaphor.
>> Yeah. Metaphor.
>> Yeah. Can you show that it's a metaphor
in its context, bro?
>> In context?
>> Yes. You have to have the context that
shows that it's metaphorical. Cuz it's
not metaphorical.
So nothing in the in the in the verse or
the context of the verse suggest that
>> of
what about the verse? The verse says if
Allah wanted to have a son Oh, excuse
me.
>> If Allah wanted to have a son, he could.
That's what the verse says, right?
>> No, you don't say.
>> The verse doesn't say. Okay, hold on.
Let's Let's just go ahead
>> and let's read the verse.
>> Let's read the verse together.
Chapter 39:4
because it sounds like you're being
dishonest with your own book. And that's
what you guys usually do. You guys hate
the book. You guys hate the Quran. I
know, but it's okay. This is what it
says, ladies and gentlemen. I said you
guys hate the Quran. You You as a
Muslim, you hate the Quran. You hate the
book.
>> Why?
>> Because it goes against everything you
say.
>> No, you hate the Bible cuz you've
changed the Bible.
>> I got you. So, this is what it says
here, ladies and gentlemen. Chapter 39:4
it says if Allah intended to take a son
he could have
he could have chosen from what he
creates and whatever he willed exalted
is he he is Allah the one the prevailing
so is that metaphorical or does Allah
actually say if he wanted to he could
have a son
>> I'm doing you one more time it's mate
for
>> all right take your mate for in the
comment section
>> okay
>> off the stage
>> I was I don't even know what would be a
metaphor for in the first place. Like it
doesn't make any sense.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Guys, you won't last long if
you're dishonest. If you're dishonest
and you are um you know, you just
playing you just playing games with us
and you playing games with your own
book. You're not going to last long.
You're not going to last long at all.
Your Quran just said that Allah could
have a son if he wanted to. If you're
going to say it's a mif, then you're
going to have to demonstrate how in the
context. That's just lying. Just throw
metaphor anywhere. Oh, it's a metaphor.
Get out of here. All right, let's try uh
this should go quickly.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Good evening.
>> Afternoon.
>> So, so now Avery, you're against the
professor with a lot of bravery and I'm
going to take you down. Are you ready?
>> That was a bar. I don't even know if you
caught that.
>> Yeah. I'm also a lyricist.
>> That's what I'm talking about. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, open up the Quran chapter 18
verse4 and verse 5 and read them. Or I
can read them and recite them for you in
Arabic. Well, the Arabic would do me no
good, but go ahead and recite it in
English.
>> That's because you you're learned by
pagan Romans. You don't know the
language of God. You know the language
of pagans.
>> So therefore,
>> God God only has one language.
>> Yes. Arabic and the Samic language is
>> so Oh, so he doesn't have only one. You
just you just named one language.
>> Are you listening? The root the divine
language is Arabic. Well, phonetic
languages are dialects of that root
language we call.
>> Is Hebrew and Arabic a different
language?
>> No, they're sister languages, but Arabic
is the true divine language.
>> Those are the same language.
>> Come on, let's get on with the verse.
>> Is Hebrew love doing this?
I really wanted to make this claim for
some reason.
>> Is Hebrew, bro? Is Hebrew and Arabic the
same language? Since you're an expert on
Hebrew and Arabic and Aramaic,
>> the question I say now,
>> is Hebrew and and Arabic the same
language?
>> Do you know what sister languages mean?
>> Answer the question. Are Hebrew and
Arabic the same language?
>> I've just said they are sister
languages.
>> That's not what I asked. I said, are
they the same language?
>> Obviously, your brain can't comprehend
the answer, so I
>> It's a yes or a no. It's a true
dichotoous question. Is Arabic and
Hebrew the same language? Yes or no?
>> Ultimatums are for fools and are you a
fool? There's no way.
>> Hey, you you got you got full mod. Just
to let you know, you got full
moderation.
>> Yeah. Listen, I'm going ask you one more
time, RZ. If you don't answer the
question, we're going to have to move
on, bro.
>> All right. Okay. I'll answer the
question. Avery, are you jealous that
your boyfriend just got 6K in likes or
money?
>> Yeah, he's gone, buddy.
>> All right. We're going to give you guys
We'll give y'all another What is he
talking about, man?
>> God's language is Arabic. He only speaks
one language but also Hebrew and Aramaic
which are sister languages of Arabic uh
the same they're all one language and
sister languages at the same time
>> the same language but Arabic is a divine
language and Hebrew isn't the divine
lang the same language
snack bar
>> leader
>> yeah hello
>> you ready to lead us into some confusion
>> no I'm ready to lead you into guidance
man
>> all right lead us into guidance we'll
Yeah, we'll see what we'll see what
direction this goes.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So, Islam versus
Christianity. Uh do you do you agree
that there uh contradictions in the
Bible in your holy scripture?
>> No. Do you believe do you agree that
there's contradictions in your Quran, in
your holy scripture?
>> Uh no.
>> Can I show you one?
>> No, I don't. Yeah. But I also want to
talk to you about one contradiction in
the Bible. So,
>> we'll do we'll do that next. Let me show
Yeah, we'll do that next.
>> But one for one.
>> Yep. One for one. You ready?
>> All right. Fine.
>> All right. Go to surah 12.
>> Surah 12. I don't think you guys can
hear me when I log out of
>> that is correct. But I still want you to
be able to look at the verse yourself.
>> Okay. But which verse is it?
>> It's the very last verse. 111. Shoot up.
>> If you have it indicated by shouting, I
got it. Preacher.
>> Which chap which chapter was it?
>> He went off the screen and just go
search something. He didn't know what
the freak he was.
>> You didn't you didn't know what chapter
that I gave you when you went off the
screen. You said chapter 12, but then
you said 111. So
>> why why why did I say 111?
>> 111 means chapter 1 verse 11, right?
>> No, after I said 12. Why do you think I
said 111, man? Are you all there? You
okay?
>> Uh yeah. Yeah, I am. Like those are two
different chapters now.
>> No,
>> 111. Chapter 11.
>> There's got to be satire. There's no
way.
>> One is a chapter reference.
>> Yeah.
>> And the other is a verse reference that
you asked for. You forgot that you asked
the verse.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I did 111. That's not a
verse number, man. That's a chapter and
a verse itself,
>> bro.
>> 111 as 111. Oh, okay. I thought you said
111. One color.
>> Your brains get fried when you go to
Islam. This can't be,
>> man. Get off that hashish, man.
>> Oh my god.
>> Stay off that hashish, please.
>> Say say no to it. Say no to the hash. No
dates, man. It's crazy. Come on, man.
>> Stay off that black human.
>> You there yet?
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've read the
verse.
>> All right. So, it says that the Quran is
a confirmation of what came before it, a
detailed explanation of all things, a
guidance, and a mercy for all who
believe. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, the part we're going to
be focusing on is the part where it says
that it's a detailed explanation of all
things. Okay.
>> Oh, perfect. Perfect. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, what's the problem?
>> No problem. Yeah. Now, what I want you
to do is I want you to keep your keep a
comma on that or maybe just open us
another tab where you can have these
both up at the same time. Okay? I want
you to have this verse up and I want you
to put this next verse next to it. All
right? You ready?
>> All right. Yeah.
>> Chapter three.
>> Chapter 3.
>> Verse
number seven.
>> What was the chapter?
>> All right. Chapter 3 verse 7.
>> Chapter 3 verse 7.
>> Yeah.
All right. So, you see how that verse
says that the Quran has clear verses and
the Quran has unclear verses. There are
some verses that are clear and specific.
There are others that are unspecific or
ambiguous.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I see that.
>> All right. So, my question to you is
this. Can the Quran
be a detailed explanation of all things?
Not some, not a part, but a detailed
explanation of all things while also
having verses that aren't detailed and
explained, that aren't specific and
clear.
>> So ambiguous, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, can you have ambiguous statements
which explain stuff in detail?
>> That's not what I asked. If you can
answer the question first and then ask
your next question, I promise you this
will go well.
>> Just answer stuff directly and you'll be
all right. Now,
>> can the Quran be detailed be a detailed
explanation of all things
>> while at the same time have verses that
are unclear and unspecific, not fully
detailed?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's possible.
>> So, for the person who asked about A and
non A earlier, this is exhibit A of
that.
>> Yeah.
>> Exhibit A. The Quran is a detailed
explanation of all things. Other
statement, there are things in the Quran
that aren't detailed and explained.
That's both a and non. And he's saying
that they both can exist at the same
time. They both can be true.
>> Yeah.
>> Because there can be ambiguous
statements which explain stuff in
detail.
>> Yeah. What does it mean? Wait, what does
it mean to be ambiguous
>> to I mean I I would describe it as not
being not being a bit vague. How
>> not detailed, right?
>> Not detailed, but that doesn't mean you
describe.
>> So you're saying it can be ambiguous and
detailed. But ambiguous means not
detailed.
>> I never said that. I said it can
describe stuff.
>> It was 20 It was 20 seconds ago he said
this.
>> No, that's not what I said, man. I said
it can describe stuff in detail.
>> You literally said it can be both
ambiguous and detailed.
>> But can you tell me why can't it be
ambiguous and still not describe stuff
in detail?
>> Because definitionally to be ambiguous
means to not be detailed.
>> Definitionally it means to not be in
detail. But I'm saying can it describe
stuff in detail? Can nondetailed stuff
describe stuff in detail? If it
describes if it describes stuff in
detail, it would not be ambiguous.
Leader, remember I said you was going to
lead us into confusion.
>> By definition, if something is
ambiguous, it's lacking detail. You
understand?
>> Yeah.
>> Yet the Quran says that it's a detailed
explanation of all things. So if it's a
definite if if it's a if it is an
explanation of all things, excuse me, if
it's a detailed explanation of all
things, then therefore it cannot be
ambiguous.
>> All right, perfect. So when it says it's
a detailed description for everything,
it means it's describing stuff in
detail.
>> It doesn't say describe, it says
explain. It is a detailed explanation
of all things. So it explains in detail
everything it talks about. If it doesn't
then the statement is false. If it does
then the other statement is false.
>> All right. But can you tell me if why
can't you have an ambiguous statement
which describes something in detail?
>> Shut your stupid get off my stage.
>> This can't be bro. We don't know
definitional contradictions anymore. I
guess
>> he asked the same question. last one and
then we we we rocking with YouTube man
because these tick tik tok is you guys
are man I mean when I say bottom of
barrel like scrub off the shoe like man
this is crazy just dumb man breed dumb
breed